hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to give you some advice
uh as regards using slang
now my advice up front is don't try to
learn slang
or at least don't try don't try to
deliberately learn the slang don't use
slang until you are ready for it slang
is difficult
uh it's very easy to grab a hold of some
slang terms and throw them into your
language hoping that they're appropriate
I'm hoping that it'll create a great
impression but it's very very difficult
to pull off now I know some of you will
immediately say well Steve is old what
does he know young people like to use
slang
maybe but I can tell you that it's
difficult to use it's constantly
changing what's you know modern slang
today maybe
out of fashion
by the time you find that slang term and
try to use it
um we if you spend a lot of time with
people who are using slang and it
becomes sort of very much a part of your
language environment then at some point
you will start naturally using it if on
the other hand you get a dictionary of
slang or a list of popular slang words
in Colombia or in and Ecuador or you
know or in Germany or whatever language
you're learning and you say okay I'm
going to use those words and that's
going to make me sound more authentic
most of the time it won't make you sound
authentic it'll make it'll somehow to
the native speaker comes across comes
across as strange in other words there
is a point
in our use of language where we
naturally start to use words that we
have heard and we have heard them so
often that we know exactly what they
mean and we know exactly how they're
used now the same can be said for other
words until you've heard particular
words or phrases often enough you're not
totally confident that you can use them
correctly all of that is true but it's a
bigger issue with slang because with
slang we're almost saying you know I'm
totally cool and up on the latest slang
and you sort of present yourself as
someone who naturally uses these slang
terms but if you aren't in fact a person
who naturally uses those slang terms
then the impression created is often
negative you may get some laughs but it
doesn't give the impression that you are
a competent user of the language and by
slang I you know refer to sort of turn
terms uh you know terms you know hey
dude you can say dude but if you don't
feel totally comfortable calling someone
dude don't call them dude uh
comes a point there will be a point
where you're comfortable using that term
but until then and it'll come out
naturally it's like so much in language
learning even you know polite language
in in Japanese I don't make a deliberate
attempt to learn polite forms so that at
some point I'm gonna Trot out this
polite form I sort of speak a neutral
form of the language and at some point I
will have heard these polite terms so
often that it'll just be natural for me
to use the more polite form in a certain
situation however most of the time if I
use the sort of a neutral form of the
language that works nobody in Japan is
ever offended if you use the literal
form however if you use a too familiar
slangy form of the language with someone
who is not say of your in-group that can
create a bit of a winsing uh on the part
of the person who hears it whereas if
you stay with neutral language you can't
go wrong now as with so many things in
language it depends on the language
environment that you are a part of it's
a bit like this you know deliberately
learning you know business English or
academic English
uh slang in many ways is more difficult
than business English or academic
English you have to have a very you know
strong sense of the sort of sensitivity
of when to use certain slang words and
when not or even certain abbreviations
there's a tendency because you hear I'm
Gonna Wanna
you exaggerate ganawanda you think the
thing to say is I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna I wanna do this I say I wanna I
gonna I say it naturally I don't
deliberately say I I mean I try I think
I'm saying I'm going to but I end up
saying I'm gonna
or I wanna instead of I want to but the
learner should train him or herself to
say I want to I'm going to and gradually
over time it'll become I'm gonna want to
you know in French for example
but after a while you start naturally
saying
but at least in your mind you're saying
you're trying to stay with the sort of
neutral form of the language and
naturally
certain slang expression certain
contractions certain forms of the
language will creep into your language
because you've heard it so often and
you're sort of
you know instinctively using those forms
in which case it's fine but if you
deliberately say boy you know the really
cool French people they don't say Jonas
they probably say shipa so I'm going to
say shipa it'll it'll sound funny it
won't work
all of this is of course even more true
with swear words swear words are
difficult to use be very careful make
sure you're comfortable with how these
words are used who will appreciate you
using them and probably your best advice
is to stay away from them uh and I was
referring by the way to business English
or academic English those are again
forms of the language where because you
are are in an environment which is a
business so business Japanese I spent
you know most of my Japanese language
interactions while living in Japan where
with business people and specifically
relating to the wood business so I
became very familiar with terms and in
fact a lot of the customers were from
the Kansai so all kinds of sort of
Kansai in other words Osaka area
you know Expressions intonations
naturally became a part of how I speak
Japanese I don't I didn't deliberately
go out to try and sound more like
someone from Osaka but people have told
me that there are times when my Japanese
seems to reflect a certain Kansai
influence it happens naturally so I
think we want to allow our language to
develop naturally based on who we're
talking to what subject matter we're
dealing with and not to try to
deliberately learn you know slang or
swear words or as I say you know
business Japanese business French
business if you are with people enough
if you read enough material if you
listen to enough material which has a
certain form of the language you will
naturally start to speak that way and so
I would advise people to place the
emphasis on acquiring different ways of
speaking Naturally by putting yourself
in situations where you're hearing that
form of the language a lot and to avoid
deliberately trying to impress people
with uh slang or your interpretation of
how people are speaking that you think
are very cool and you would like to be
like them rather let the process happen
naturally now I hope that doesn't sound
too much like an old fuddy daddy like me
uh funny that he's probably a slang a
very outdated slang maybe now the
equivalent would be Boomer or some such
term at any rate that those are my views
on slang I hope that was helpful
and I'll leave you with a couple of
videos that talk about using different
forms of the language in different
situations thank you for listening